hear the yell back to school with norman
fell brand new shoes
i have to say i've always whenever i
hear that is our theme song by the
brilliant jack white whenever i hear
that tune or when i sing that song i
have to say if i was here hear the yell
back to school with norman fell it's
stupid so i admit that norman fell do
you know norman no idea who that is did
you ever watch three's company i did
remember mr roper yeah norman fell but
why do i need to know his real name
because he's a human being he did a
great brilliant
mr roper no
you can't great argument he's also in
ocean
you should know people's work can i tell
you something i just don't understand
why i need to know the names of the
actors who played these roles on 70s
television shows because i would tsa
might quiz you also yeah the tsa could
you could get yanked off a plane at any
moment and
they will ask you basic questions about
american pop culture and you need to
know them second of all how do you like
it that on the internet you're mostly
known as crazy conan lady
is that right yes she's just crazy conan
lady on the internet they don't even
know your name wouldn't you prefer if
they knew that you're played by sonum
obsession i think that
i've been with her so many times she's
like people will come up to me on the
street and i'm often with sono because
i'm showing her the errands that i want
her to do
and
so this is where they do the dry
cleaning and stuff and if you could pick
it up and she's like [ __ ] you i don't do
that for you go [ __ ] yourself and um
so and then we get into a slap fight but
people are always coming up to me going
oh my god it's conor o'brien that's
sorry that's just my life and it's
embarrassing to admit but um you bring
it up a lot i'm sorry but oh my god oh
my god oh my god shaz which is the sound
of them having diarrhea
excuse me seriously excuse me
can i say something and this is a true
this is a real thing when we were at
warner brothers there was a tour
remember the tour um bus that went
around at warner brothers the train yes
yeah yeah yeah and
so they'd get to see like oh my god
there's this star there's that star and
i don't like to brag and i'm i'm can't
believe i'm going to like to brag i
don't i don't i really
i don't it makes me uncomfortable okay
i'm like johnny depp during the trial
when he said this is embarrassing but
anyway we went to get clean i went to
the island that i own
and he actually said that he said i
don't know how to say this it's rather
embarrassing but uh i retreated to my
island
and i'm like
what anyway the tour you know they drive
it around the warner brothers lot and
whenever they would pass me they had to
actually put in special grading in the
seats underneath
people got so excited when they saw me
wow
that everyone would get diarrhea so they
put a grate at the bottom of the tram at
warner brothers to catch the diarrhea in
a giant tank what makes you think that's
them excited oh it was they were very
excited and the sound was shaz no it was
chess and it got to the point where
sometimes it was so loud that if actor
chaz palminteri was nearby yeah he used
to come by and say am i wanted or was it
a conancider and we would go we're sorry
mr palmentary
the tramps and he'd be like i know the
tram saw conan and he was always very
good-natured about it but whenever the
tram the tram would go by oh look
there's jennifer aniston they'd be like
oh wow i can't believe it one of the
friends or they'd go buy another you
know oh look there's christian bale he's
shooting the new batman yeah okay
whatever and then they would see conan
and then chaz palmitary goes running
through the warner brothers gate and you
go like me or die or conan diarrhea and
then we'll go it's it's conan would chas
ever shaz once
one time chaz palmitary i was having
dinner with him and he said let me get
it this time and he one time picked up
the bill but he didn't look at it first
he forgot that we weren't you know he
likes we both of us used to usually eat
at the olive garden but we were like a
really craig's which is more expensive
and he the bill came and it was
it was not what he expected and i heard
jess
yeah it was one guy it wasn't
a whole tram full of people having
diarrhea when they see conan is josh
but
chas palmitary having quick
staccato-like diarrhea when he sees
800 for two club sandwiches yes
anyway
um
that i know who chaz palmintery is okay
you do that was a little flight of fancy
but it's good that's what happens people
see me they get really excited chaz then
they see you and go oh my god and you're
crazy conan lady
yeah
i um
you get that a lot right oh you're that
conan person it's just that like okay so
a lot of the shows that you guys watch i
feel like are reruns probably like you
actually pay attention to the credits
when they're rolling i always did that
yes i
you know i put that into a simpsons
episode i know you did oh i didn't know
that wow you didn't know that i did i
didn't know that i did that i didn't
know that i knew that i didn't you do
you know no no i
i used to watch the credits because i
was and i knew a lot of names i didn't
know who did what exactly yeah but
certain things and closed by botany 500
i i just like what's botany what could
that mean i think it was the dick van
dyke show didn't they have so no many
game shows there were so many it's a
wardrobe stylist company but it doesn't
make sense because botany's a science
and 500's a number why is that
clothing you oh you're right all other
clothing names make sense yeah except
that one hey listen no clothes make
sense no clothes make sense no but also
very few things like why is esso a gas
station
what you know
botany 500 is so specifically other
things
okay i can't with you guys you know what
this is if you're in the should be
embarrassed you know what you know what
can i say something if you stay in the
dorm room too late and they start
talking about what's at the end of the
universe but what's after that yeah
that's th this is that dorm room yeah it
is yeah because you're also holding a
guitar you are yeah no that was not a
cue
no
play play us out botany 500. play us out
we just got it started
um jazz this one's for jazz
has commentaries listening right now
he's like why
what did i do